ross tucker from the ross tucker
football podcast welcome to the show
ross how you doing buddy
ryan i'm doing great man thank you so
much for having me happy draft day yeah
happy draft day uh it's
uh it's always fun to reminisce i i just
talked to the guys here and all our
viewers and listeners about my theory or
my philosophy when it comes to drafting
players and what the nfl
has become and to me it's all about the
passer
the guy that protects the passer and the
guy that rushes the passer
and there are a bunch of offensive
linemen this year that fit that role
and i don't want to see teams reach
for flashy ferraris and wide receivers
and you know no need running backs when
you got offensive linemen that
need to protect your passer what are
your thoughts about that and where do
you think tonight goes in terms of
what happens after all the quarterbacks
go well listen i mean we all know
quarterbacks the most important position
uh i think there's some debate as to
what the second most important position
is
i've often said i think it's d-line
because i think uh an individual d-line
or a group of defensive linemen can have
a bigger impact
than the o-line i think all lines third
i i agree with you i guess ryan because
i think it's
quarterback one d-line two o-line three
the thing that's interesting about
o-line versus d-line though
is if you have one outstanding d
lyman like an aaron donald or whoever
right
they can really make a huge impact but
if you have one outstanding offensive
lineman
that's nice i mean it's really nice to
have that
but the reality is what really matters
is how that
unit does as a group your own in other
words you're almost
only as good as your worst o lineman up
front i'd rather have
five average offensive lineman
then have two studs and two duds if that
makes sense right so
whereas drafting a d-lineman high that
one guy
can make a huge impact on the o-line
you really just can't have anybody that
stinks like you can't everybody out
there
that can't play as long as you all five
guys
are average or better you'll actually be
in pretty good shape
well i i think that's exactly right and
that's why
when teams are cl or fans are clamoring
about no no no don't draft another
offensive lineman we got one a year ago
no you you build the best offensive line
you can in whatever that takes
so when i hear um people coming out of
cincinnati saying that
they're going to draft jamar chase at
number five
rather than penne sewell to bolster that
offensive line which was the liability a
year ago that got their franchise
quarterback
on the gurney headed out of the stadium
it shocks me what do you think the
bengals will
do but what should they do at number
five when they have their name called
well so that's interesting right for a
couple different reasons
because number one
it's a pretty deep o-line group but it's
also a pretty deep
wide receiver group so if you think i
mean i know people out there ryan that
will say
jamar chase is the best wide receiver
prospect since at least 2015. i had a
guy
on the fantasy feast podcast who
you know tracks all the numbers well
jamar chased it at age 19
and the sec is just insane so if you're
the bengals
you could look at it like man jamar
chase is so
much better than any other receivers
and at the top of round two we could
still
get a really good starting offensive
lineman whether that's
landon dickerson inside or liam
eichenberg from notre dame at tackle
sam cosmi from texas so i think
you know and if you're only looking at
the first round pick
i think you lean towards the offensive
line but if you're looking at those as a
combo
over the first couple rounds you know
you have to decide would you rather have
chase and eichenberg or sewell
and like rondale moore or one of these
slot receivers
right i really do think that's how a lot
of these teams look at it
and that's how i would look at it too
i'd look at an opportunity just like it
is with a running back in that second or
third round you can get those guys
justin jefferson a year ago was as good
as anybody but that didn't change the
wins and losses right
he wasn't he wasn't the deciding factor
that puts
the because they still need somebody to
get him the football and the quarterback
play had been better there so that's
that's what we're looking at tonight uh
the san francisco 49ers
have what people consider the
the hinge vote or the hinge choice in in
determining where this
first round goes and and how the
dominoes will fall i think it really
comes down to the third and fourth picks
in in san francisco
and atlanta but all the speculation
around who goes third uh and the move
that the 49ers made
we're about time ross where where did
the 49ers go tonight
uh with that third overall pick i'm
still
saying mac jones and it sounds like
there's a little bit more buzz today
about trey lance potentially there at
number three but
i'm still saying mac jones for a couple
reasons number
one chris sims who maybe you already had
or you're gonna have on the show today
you know he and kyle shanahan have like
matching ankle tattoos or something
and he right when it happened he said
mac jones
i don't i don't picture you know how
shane doesn't have to be
quiet about it you know they knew that
it's gonna be lawrence at one and wilson
at two
i don't think he would you know put
chris sims on the wrong track
if you didn't have to but i'll go even a
step further
right i remember i think it was like
2010
it was the first year for the shanahan
in washington
i went to washington training camp and i
was talking with kyle
it was first year that i was telling him
i was just talking about how he had
absolutely tore up the league
with the houston texans i mean it the
texans put up crazy numbers
when kyle was their oc and you know
andre johnson the whole deal and he
looked at me and he said
quarterback is really good i said yeah
matt child's pretty quick
no no quarterbacks really good
so what i know from talking with him and
from what other people said he really
loves
guys like shaw been cousins he really i
think
and you know how coaches are ryan i
think he really just wants the guy
to execute what he tells them to do he
doesn't want
the variance like you know lance or
maybe fields or whoever
are more talented and can do some things
that a guy like mack jones couldn't
but he doesn't care about the upside
he just doesn't want the downside
variance he just wants his quarterback
to do what he tells him to do throw it
to that to the right guy
and throw it accurately like shauban
cousins do
and is that isn't that why ross he's
he's loved jimmy garoppolo so much and
why he stuck with them i think through
through the thick and thin is because he
does that it's just it's it's so
limiting in in the eyes of other people
uh that he's kind of had to make a
concession here
i don't i don't know that he has loved
jimmy g that much i mean it feels like
you know last year they tried to get
brady
it feels like every year they've tried
to upgrade
that spot i mean i i think he really
wanted
to get cousins back in the day but they
realized that that might not be able to
happen
and jimmy g was available the patriots
called i mean
it's one of the weirdest trades ever
that doesn't get talked about enough
the patriots literally just called the
niners and offered him jimmy g
you know there were other teams out
there that would have given up more
for jimmy g but belichick wanted to
trade him
to kyle shanahan and the niners
specifically for whatever reason i mean
i remember
some reports out there where team said
yeah we were a little surprised that
we didn't get a chance so i don't know
that
kyle has ever really loved jimmy g as
much
as that was the best quarterback option
that was available
when belichick called them if that's the
case we're talking to ross tucker
uh from the ross tucker football podcast
at russ
tucker nfl on twitter um
if that's the case um is jimmy
garoppolo along for that locker room
after
tonight's pick is announced
no i already tweeted this he'll be a
patriot by the end of the weekend
i mean i would be stunned i always say
stunned
i think there's a better than 50 chance
that the patriots trade a low round pick
because i don't think there's gonna be
that many
like who else would be interested in
jimmy g maybe the bears but i tend to
doubt it
i think you could make the argument the
texans with nick casario
would be interested if they anticipate
getting rid
of desean watson uh for whatever reason
or that maybe desean won't be able to
play this year
but i really think it's new england i i
don't think the patriots are gonna trade
up i'm not buying that
i don't think they're gonna get a
quarterback in the first round i think
they trade
a late round pick for jimmy g they know
him
they like him he's still young he knows
their offense
i think that just like they thought four
years ago or whatever it was
i think that mcdaniels and belichick
think jimmy g's really good
and they can win a bunch of games with
him and then get him for a late round
pick
and they'll probably even make the
niners take on some of jimmy g's salary
for this year
so i really i i'd almost be surprised
ryan if that doesn't happen
all right running backs uh pittsburgh
steeler fans out there clamoring for
the possibility of travis atn or naji
harris in that spot
uh is there a running back you think
that goes in the first round and
and should there be one because i to
your point earlier
you can find these guys later down in
the draft process
um but giving up or or wasting a first
round draft pick on a player that maybe
isn't necessarily the only hole you have
um
which one is the right fit for for a
team in the first round
well it's interesting because you know
talking with different folks
on the raw sucker podcast you know
there's actually three really good
running backs
etn naji harris and javonte williams at
unc
who i absolutely love like that guy is a
monster
i love javonte williams i wouldn't be
surprised if he went
in the first round but there's actually
a pretty decent drop off after that
you know most of the other guys people
say are more like fourth fifth six
rounders
so that's another one of those where you
could say if you're the steelers
or whoever you could say okay we take
what we think is the best running back
at 24
and then get a starting caliber
offensive lineman
in round two because there's just more
of them so i think that elements
interesting because usually there's a
lot of depth at running back and it
feels like this year for whatever reason
there's really not um i like javonte
williams i
and there's positives of etn there's
positives of naji harris but
wow i think a lot of people north
carolina doesn't play as many
nationally televised games as clemson
alabama
but that dude is awesome like making
guys miss
breaking tackles i think he's a monster
ross tucker we're talking to here from
the ross tucker podcast former nfl
offensive lineman talk to us about your
draft uh what
what that was like what uh leading up to
it and everything like that we we
discussed a little bit about
what it was like 23 years ago for me and
how much it's
changed and the hoopla and the
extravaganza that we're going to see
play out
in real time tonight so what's funny
about that ryan is uh
mine was 2001 uh so
20 years ago and i was such a bottom of
the barrel prospect
that i knew i wasn't getting drafted my
agent
actually joe linta he's got like you
know joe flacco
and used check and cam bray and a bunch
of guys he gets a lot of ivy league guys
he said to me 50 50 whether or not i
would even get
signed right he even gets signed so i
sat there and watched every second of
the draft
i only got two phone calls one in the
first round and one in like the fifth
round each day
and both calls were from the cincinnati
bengals
so you have to remember like you know
this ryan because you're 98 but
in 2001 the bengals were the worst
of the worst they hadn't had a winning
season in 10 years
but when my phone rang in the first
round i
was like i'm ready i'm ready to be a
bagel
um meanwhile they were just saying uh
hey ross if you don't get drafted we
might be interested in you i think oh
okay but i'm ready now like if you want
me now i'm ready so the funny thing
about it is my agent ryan
jolente said the longer it waits for me
to call you
after the draft the worst the sign is
the worst of it so i i was in there
dude all my college roommates and
teammates
had gone out every night second semester
of senior year i got up at 5 00 a.m like
to train
i sat there for an hour after the draft
nothing nothing so finally
i'm starving i go out to the eating club
yes it sounds fancy it probably
is so i got to the eating club they're
all outside
grilling having beers and i'm like you
know i'm starving
i couldn't eat like i got out there
nobody would even look at me
nobody would talk to me because they
could just tell on my face
how upset i was i walked back to my dorm
room
as i'm walking up the steps i hear my
phone ring i'm like on the third floor
so i start sprinting up the steps i grab
my phone
and it's joe lint and he says ross i
said what
like where have you been and i said i
you told me it would take a while if it
took a long time to call me that i
wasn't gonna get signed i was hungry
he's like well
you're the newest member of the
washington redskins at the time right
uh washington football team now that was
i mean i went from as low as i've ever
been in my life
thinking i just gave up my whole second
semester senior year of partying
for nothing to getting signed
i ran back out to the eating club i walk
out into the courtyard where everybody
is
and i just say to my buddies redskins
and they all went crazy we started
jumping up and down
everybody was excited all the girls were
looking over at me i was like yeah see
see you should hung out with me too bad
now it was awesome
oh god draft day stories man that's
that's a good one that is a good one for
sure yeah you are
you are listless and then overjoyed in
a matter of moments uh thank you ross
tucker
ross tucker football podcast for joining
us to have a great rest of the draft day
we're so excited to see how it all plays
out thanks again bud
yeah my pleasure thanks for having me
i'm listening on uh siriusxm 211 very
curious to hear
how brockman feels about jimmy g coming
back to new england
i'll be listening to you no russ let's
just talk about it right now i
i have zero interest in jimmy garoppolo
zero
what's what is the point of every every
patriot fan is saying that chris why do
you say that
okay then why are you bringing him in is
he gonna back up cam newton or is he
gonna be the starting quarterback
he's gonna be the starting quarterback
because they believe
he's better than cam newton then why did
they sign cam and give him a raise if
they were just gonna trade for jimmy
this whole time
because they didn't know they were just
going to trade for jimmy this whole time
because they didn't know the niners were
going to trade up to three
to get mack jones
who's the third quarterback on the
roster then because these guys
shelf life isn't isn't much longer cam's
on a one year
and jimmy's been hurt most of the last
three seasons
yeah drop like a uh jimmy g
ryan mallet you know second third fourth
round dude
i just don't understand i just don't get
the upside of this move
so the upside it well i mean chris he's
still pretty young
and they think he's pretty good i mean i
think they think in hit in their offense
you know they could be a perennial
playoff team i mean he just took a team
two years ago to the super bowl
and was one pass away from winning it
and i think that they think that they're
as good as the niners are so i think
that
and and i think the other part about it
is
i just think that they want to have a
winning record and get to the playoffs i
just think
belichick knows that everybody is paying
attention
to what he's doing they all know what
brady did last year
they all know what he did last year and
i think if nothing else
he believes he can win more games with
garoppolo this year and figure out
the future uh later depending on how
jimmy does
it's fair and and i totally get that but
then you got to take
the cam newton part into it cam has
dedicated himself to this team
uh he's been there voluntary workouts
we've all seen the work he's putting in
he got a raise in his year deal this
year and you're just gonna tell him
thanks no thanks you're the backup now i
i just don't see that sitting well
well i think that they'll uh i think
they'll let them compete i think they'll
let them compete and ultimately play
whoever is they think is best for the
job plus both those guys
get injured a lot you know they've got a
lot of injury issues that's the one
thing i think is interesting chris
i don't know if you know this but in the
patriots training room
there's a huge sign that says
the most important ability is
availability
right so that's the one thing i don't
know about belichick
and jimmy g is i guess i
wonder how much the injuries
in san francisco have turned him off now
maybe it has i
got i don't know right but that's
very very important in new england very
important
so i wonder if the only thing that would
prevent them in my mind from going for
jimmy g
is if they're just concerned about how
how often he gets hurt
yeah and i know we got to go ross and
thanks for joining us but even the one
year he got
a chance to play when tom was suspended
he got hurt
he got hurt yeah jacoby had to come out
exactly yeah you know what
um god doesn't make many people that
good-looking and durable you know what i
mean like
clearly clearly with your picture and
your beard yeah
i i agree with that ross tucker
everybody uh from the roster football
podcast thanks for joining us
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here